نحن نتابع أحد فرق تتبع جهات الاتصال
في إسطنبول التي التقينا بها للتو ،
فهم يتواجدون هناك
كل يوم في محاولة لتجميع
القرائن التي تربط النقاط حول كيفية
انتشار الفيروس ، وتنسب تركيا
الكثير من نجاحه  ضد
فيروس كورونا اختار حقيقة أنه
قادر على تتبع الاتصال بقوة للغاية ،
فهناك حوالي 6000 فريق في جميع أنحاء
البلاد وهم موجودون باستمرار
يسألون عن تاريخها الطبي ، لذا فهي
تعاني من ارتفاع ضغط الدم ، وكانت تشكو
من سيلان في الأنف ، اتصل بها ابنها.
عند اتصالك بشخص
ثبتت إصابته سابقًا أنه على
وشك أخذ
عينة لمسحها ، يستغرق الأمر حوالي 24
ساعة حتى تعود النتائج ، وإذا انتهى
الأمر بنتائج إيجابية ، فهذه هي
نقطة الانطلاق لجهة اتصال أخرى
ما
يفعلونه الآن هو في الواقع تسجيل
ابنها في نظامهم الداخلي ،
إنه تطبيق يسمح لهم بتتبع
كل من يحتاج إلى  تم عزله
وآخرين أيضًا لأن الابن
هو في الواقع على اتصال بشخص
مصاب بفيروس كوفات ، فقد يكون أو
لم يكن هو الشخص الذي نقله إلى
والدته ، ولكن في كلتا الحالتين ، يتعين عليه الآن
البقاء في الحجر الصحي لمدة 14 يومًا و  إذا
كسر الناس الحجر الصحي ، فقد
تكون العواقب وخيمة جدًا تتراوح
بين دفع غرامة أو حتى أثناء فترة السجن
اعتبارًا من اليوم الأول لتركيا
بالفعل خطة جائحة داخل
النظام من الأوبئة السابقة ، لذلك كنا
دائمًا مستعدين
لمن أخذ الخطة على الرف  ضعه
موضع التنفيذ وقم بتنبيه جميع
وحدات تتبع جهات الاتصال الخاصة بنا ، لذلك لم نضيع
الوقت للتخطيط للرد أو لنقول ما
يجب على المستشفيات فعله أثناء هذه الكارثة ،
فهذه هي العملية التي لديهم
أشخاص يتحدثون التركية والعربية ،
لذا هنا الآن  هو في الواقع على
الهاتف مع شخص ما يحاول الحصول على
سجلهم فيما يتعلق بمكان وجودهم ومن
كانوا على اتصال مع
د.  يخبرنا أصلان أنه
يتعين عليهم الاعتماد على الناس ليكونوا صادقين
لأنه إذا لم يكن لديهم
معلومات دقيقة ، فيمكنهم السير في
الاتجاه الخاطئ
Arwa Damon CNN Istanbul